Yosemite National Park is opened this
morning after a second massive rockslide
in two days
injured another park visitor a man was
seriously hurt
yesterday when large chunks of rock fell
off the face of elcapitan a similar
rockslide at the popular rock wall on
Wednesday killed a British tourist
parameters inside Yosemite National Park
in California near El Capitan Carter
good morning good morning it's climbing
season here in Yosemite and this road
leads to El Capitan one of the most
popular peaks here but this is the end
of the road at least for now it's still
covered with debris after two
consecutive days of massive rock slides
looks like smoke but not again dust
hundreds of tons of granite plummeted
thousands of feet down the face of El
Capitan Thursday video captured from
inside Yosemite National Park shows the
massive dust plume billowing in the air
all of a sudden we heard sounded like
thunder Rachael Evans's husband Jim was
injured after some of the falling rock
crashed through the sunroof of their SUV
it shattered and the dust just poured a
glass went flying from the sand so we
were trying to outrun it was like go
let's go and at the same time my husband
reached up and he was like oh my head my
head
because it was bleeding profusely and
hurting he was flown by helicopter to a
nearby hospital and is expected to be ok
the rockfall slid off the southeastern
face of El Capitan a popular spot for
climbers down into the valley below this
is what it looked like on top of El
Capitan more than 7500 feet above the
slide only a day earlier a rock fall in
the same area killed a British tourist
and critically injured his wife was in
the same place and so it's possible that
the rocks were destabilized from the
event that happened yesterday geologists
say the break could have been caused by
heating and cooling of the granite as
temperatures dip the rock becomes more
brittle the last time someone was killed
by falling rock here in Yosemite was
back in 2013 Gail
all right thank you very much Carter